on retrouve tarek cas et notre envoyé
spécial ag thomert à 150 kilomètres de
kiev et à moins de 200 kilomètres de la
frontière biélorusse jette au maire
première grande ville en partant de kiev
vers l'ouest quelle est la situation sur
place
la proximité donc avec la capitale et
kiev se fait sentir ici que vous l'avez
dit nous sommes à 150 kilomètres de kiev
à près de deux heures de route la route
principale qui mène à kiev la e40 est
l'une des plus dangereuses du pays grand
tensions ici à giteau mer même si la
ville ces derniers jours n'a pas été
frappé par la mère russe cependant il
faut noter que depuis le début de ce
conflit j.tomas a été la cible de
plusieurs frappes qu'il s'agisse
d'installations militaires ou civils
parmi les cibles de civils il y avait
des quartiers résidentiels à l'hôpital
ou même une école que nous avons pu
visiter hier ici donc grande tension la
plupart des commerces sont fermés ce
qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que les
sirènes d'alarmé ont retenti ce tout au
long de la journée près de la moitié des
habitants ont quitté la ville et pour
vous donner un simple exemple notre
collaborateur à ukrainien qui connaît
cette ville sur le bout des doigts a été
extrêmement frappé hier par ce qu'il a
vu en arrivant ici le soir j'ai thomas
est une ville fantôme les rues sont
déserts
la ville donc et fantômes des rues sont
désertes et le contraste est extrêmement
important avec ce qu'il avait déjà vécu
auparavant
cette classe où je me trouve d'habitude
bondée il ya de la musique des gens de
l'activité partout la vie de jeu thomas
actuellement se prépare à se défendre
comme vous voyez derrière moi ces
obstacles antichars d'un côté de la rue
et des sacs de sable de l'autre côté et
j'ai thomert où nous avons également pu
nous entretenir avec le maire de cette
ville j'ai tonnerre qui est actuellement
qui constitue une base pour
l'acheminement de l'aide humanitaire
jusqu à kiev et qui accueille toujours
des réfugiés qui fuient ou des déplacés
qui fuient aide les bombardements alors
en parlant justement de la population
civile qui fuient les bombardements vous
avez rencontré une famille qui est
arrivé hier à alger thomert
tout à fait il s'agit d'une famille d'un
couple avec trois enfants dont deux en
bas âge qui sont complètement marque est
complètement traumatisés par ce qu'ils
ont vécu deux semaines en enfer c'est ce
que disait de la mer cette famille vient
du village de resto mail où se déroulent
actuellement les combats les plus
acharnés pour la défense de kiev ce
village là est désormais sous contrôle
de l'armée russe cette famille nous a
parlé du comportement des soldats russes
qui entrent dans les maisons qui cassent
les portes qui ont complètement
dévaliser les commerces de ce village
qui ont également coupé le gaz en disant
à la population que ce gaz vient de
russie ils ont également et l'on sait à
quel point cela peut être difficile avec
les températures qui peuvent être
négative en ce moment et s'il faut
résumer en une seule phrase une seule
phrase récurrente et incessante qui
venait justement dans la bouche de ses
habitants ses habitants donc qui ont vu
ces chars qui qui sont stationnés un peu
partout dans la ville le mouvement
incessant deux hélicoptères cette phrase
donc qui résume à peu de la situation
ils n'ont rien laissé il n'en reste plus
rien dans le village merci beaucoup ta
racaille pour vos précisions masia vos
retours